well that's it what we don't will be an
amazing is the most boring thing yeah my
kids have just discovered penny candy
stores and they're like this is the most
amazing where you find those you can
just find them in small towns I've had
them in little small towns and stuff
you're up with us right yeah bucket of
pennies here and then you go and get
your kid yeah that's for later yeah
congratulations thank you what does this
one feel like I mean you've put out so
many great albums until different okay
this one definitely feels different um
it's really hard for me to listen to
it's very emotional for me just because
all these people are people that I still
feel the same about as when I was seven
or eight and holding the records you
know and or when I was in high school
and went to see Bonnie Raitt play or my
first my second concert and saw James
Taylor and I mean it's just amazing that
all these people said yes and that I
have relationships with them and they
just brought me so far musically so it's
this one's different
so where were you and you remember
sitting down in making your wish list of
people and how did you how did that list
change from the wish list to what you're
with today and yeah what we didn't start
out to make a collaborative record I
started out working with kris
kristofferson on some of his material
and I came away from it feeling really
emotional about just wow we're all
getting older and we've all been doing
this for a very long time collaborating
on different events or different things
or guitar pools or whatever and these
moments are so special mm-hmm
I just wanted more so I called him and
said would you come to my studio and
collaborate with me and then a few weeks
later I had a song I felt like would be
really great for Stevie and I so I
called Stephen so we you did this and
she's someone I've known you know for a
really long time and it just kind of
happened organically like that and then
all of a sudden you're like I've an
album like this and it's three and a
half years later nice but you have some
voices on there that are newer to people
that you think are gonna carry through
the beautiful
message talked a little bit about that
yeah over the past few years I've got an
opportunity to go on tours like the
outlaw to Horry and me a lot of young
artists and and I've I really felt like
you know if I'm if I'm going back in
time and honoring the people or you know
tributing the people that have meant so
much to me artistically there's a huge
wealth of artists that are still
inspiring me and they're out there doing
the kind of music that's in the
tradition of all the people that have
influenced me and so I just kind of you
know started asking some people would
you want to come in and do this and do
that and people like Chris Stapleton and
Maher and Morris and Brandi Carlile and
the people I think that are going to
continue to do this kind of music that's
not based on a 6-second attention span
that's more singer/songwriter mm-hmm
so the process of doing that did people
come to your studio or did was it in the
20 you know it's like you're over here
and I'm over here and we'll FaceTime
cheering or didn't happen at all
different ways you know what do you
prefer
oh I love being in the room I mean I
called Keith Richards and said I want to
do this song the worst that you wrote
and I loved it so much and so I met him
in New York and we hung out for a couple
of days Jamaa studios he and I and Steve
Jordan who produced the record anything
stuff like that I mean that get that
can't yeah I mean there's no way you
could even write that in a script and
everybody believed it yeah same with
Emmylou Harris called her and some of
you you know she was across town she
came over and I had to send some songs
like beware of darkness I sent to Eric
Clapton and he played in his studio and
sting sang in his studio and so it
happened all different ways and then of
course Johnny Cash he had recorded that
song in 2002 and I had recorded it in
1997 so we and in the video it was quite
emotional like I thought I was watching
it last night talk a little bit about
that for yourself well this song
actually was written after I went and
performed for the troops over in
in 1997 so it was written kind of
specific to that and then in 2002 he
recorded it he called me and asked me
all kinds of questions about it and said
this is a really important song to me
it's gonna be the cornerstone of my
record and then he died a few weeks
later and then cut to now and with
everything that's happening in the
States and in the world really in
general it's very timely it's very
timely and I asked his family if I could
use the vocal and I recorded a new kind
of more somber version of it and the
video just reflects this idea that
everything that we do in our lives that
that is going to be projected of the
future our children bear witness to that
and we need to be thinking about that
you know whether it's the environment or
whether it's the way we treat each other
or whether it's our relationship to the
truth and to here Johnny
knowing what he stood for you know he
was against the Iraq war ii was against
vietnam I mean he was very outspoken
about what he believed and to hear him
singing in the words freedom and what it
means to be born into freedom and then
you've got your very emotional journey
there's you know video yes Gary